yo do y'all know who andrew tate is
i've heard i've heard of this guys
hey do you guys have any ideas have you
have you ever heard of this individual
andrew tate you guys know who he is has
he come up on your feet at all you know
and how did you mention it yeah quite a
bit so what does that say about us we
hate she doesn't want bro like
my feed it's not
you know inundated i i'm we're all
laughing because i was joking around
before about how this has never happened
before an internet history yeah
i literally believe sincerely yeah and i
mean this and you thought i was being
hyperbolic i don't i'm not i don't
never before has this happened in
history a guy that lives in romania and
does what he does there with his own
casinos
apparently
has slaves that's crazy
crazy slaves that you can't just say
people that's the allegation female sex
slaves
that makes it better i don't know
i know the rules of romania my point is
he is showing up on my feed not [ __ ]
stopping dude i'm not clicking on it
it's just next video is him in that
accent which i don't know what the [ __ ]
country is i'm just trying to figure
that [ __ ] out too god damn it bro it's a
non-stop
so cap you cooking on every single video
how crazy should this guy go to a
woman's face right now this is kind of
impressive
yeah
i'm just saying it has this ever
happened before has has one person
that has one person can't name one go go
joe rogan maybe
maybe joe rogan joe rogan has the
biggest podcast yeah i know that's my
best he still shows up on the feed less
yeah and the entire media is attacking
him on a daily basis
nobody's known what andrew tate has done
honestly
i'll be honest
he's not being crazy though
but we can't be a little bold on this
podcast make some proclamations
everybody has done that who uh kim k
when she broke the internet
you had tickets
i think his point is unknown people
unknown kanye
is a celebrity that has a whole media
apparatus dedicated to her being famous
this guy he's a decent kickboxer pretty
good i guess i don't know maybe you're
really good i don't know but we don't
[ __ ] with kickboxing like that he was
born here though and he's british
american why do we know this yeah
he has this accent
what i was trying to say before and you
guys [ __ ] on it but i think that he
needs to be hunter biden's life coach
and i mean that and i mean i mean you
guys think i'm joking about this i do i
need a justification just got well i'm
gonna make one up as we go but
you're biden yeah he hates his dad right
hates his dad yes who handles people
with daddy issues better than you
[ __ ] tape that's pretty good i
understand in the moment pretty good i
gotta give you hey buy this special
[ __ ]
bob is special
real talk well how do you know he hates
his dad why do you think he hates his
dad hunter bidens yeah there's no way
you don't bro there's he video he's
videotaping himself doing incriminating
things the only reason you would do that
the only reason is you hope that
somebody would find it and then it would
ruin your dad if you're a white guy
doing crack you're only doing it pissed
your father you hate you're dead i don't
know how you get access to crack as a
white guy
he's trying to numb the pain because
you know it's like
that's not air though you're playing
your legs
just strumming away on his thigh as some
crack [ __ ] weighs the crack
it's a lot of crap i may be doing a lot
of cracks it was short she was short
yeah who was short shorty was short
right exactly come on bro [ __ ] you come
on you've watched all the videos of whom
of hunter biden no andrew yes
yeah listen
has literally a valid point coming fox
news news one all the other truth
platforms
mark right
right 4chan all of them are non-stop all
day trying to push out information about
hunter biden i don't see close to as
many videos as i see of andrew tate on a
regular [ __ ] basis am i about
to bust out my youtube shorts right now
am i about to test this right here's
what's crazy i've been seeing him on
tick tock tick tock wow see what i'm
saying he everywhere yo he unstoppable
his youtube show instagram youtube
you're wearing your youtube shorts right
now
you were talking about
you got your youtube short song right
now
oh [ __ ] you
all i'm trying to say is hunter biden
got the serious daddy issues he's trying
he resents his father for caring so much
about politics and not about the family
at all it's something okay yeah all
right
i think we can all get on board you're
not getting on board son of a [ __ ]
pancakes what pancakes yeah i just they
did add something
i think
with andrew tate is how do you know it's
not just popping up on your thing
[Music]
you ever get in a fight with your girl
and then just tate it up for an hour
what do you mean
you don't do that cover tape
yeah you just get it you got to get a
swipe on some tape well that's it cool
no his profile cobra tape that's his
whole thing i think that was him as a
kickboxer his thing was cobra i don't
know how i know that but i know that you
know
don't know about the man it's okay no
he's undeniably funny you can't even act
like a guy not funny he's funny he's
funny bro
put a girl's body count on her forehead
solve all the problems in the world
he said that to a woman he goes you
could solve all the problems in the
world if you put a woman's body count on
her forehead oh my god come on now son
and now how does that help anything i
don't know but hunter
because it's breaking up the nuclear
family
[Laughter]